[موسيقى]
نبدا هذه النشره بالتصعيد الاسرائيلي اذا
على قطاع غزه حيث قال مصدر في المقاومه
الفلسطينيه للجزيره ان اتفاقا لوقف اطلاق
النار بدا فجر اليوم في القطاع بين
الفصائل الفلسطينيه والاحتلال الاسرائيليه
واكد المصدر للجزيره الاتفاق سيكون
متزامنا ومشروطا بالتزام الطرفين واوضح
المصدر ايضا ان الاتفاق كان نتيجه دخول
اطراف عده على خط الوساطه لوقف تصعيد
الاسرائيلي ضد القطاع وكان الطائرات
اسرائيليه قد شنت سلسله غارات على مواقع
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه في مناطق متفرقه من
قطاع غزه دون ان يبلغ عن وقوع اصابته
وبالتزامن مع الغارات اطلقت المقاومه
الفلسطينيه قضاء افسارخيه من القطاع تجاه
مستوطنات ومواقع اسرائيليه متاخمه لغسان
وقالت المقاومه ان دفاعاتها الجويه تصدت
الطائرات الاسرائيليه في اجواء القطاع
بصواريخ ارض جو